-How are you, Colton?
-Good, man. How you doing?
Good. We´ve known each other
for years and years and years.
-2001, I believe.
-2001.
We met in Amsterdam.
-That´s right.
-Because we both worked
for a comedy theater
called Boom Chicago.
-That´s right, Boom Chicago.
-A fantastic place.
A lot of our friends
got their start there.
I was there before you.
-Yeah.
-You came after me.
Did you find --
I found a little bit of culture
shock when I moved to Amsterdam.
-Oh, yeah?
-How was it for you?
-I found a lot.
A lot of culture shock, yeah.
-What was most shocking to you
culturally?
-Let´s see.
Well, probably the most shocking
part of living in Holland is
they celebrate the holidays
a little differently.
-Yeah.
-They start a little earlier.
You know?
Like, for them,
Christmas kind of starts
around the second week of
December.
-Uh-huh.
-Everybody starts putting up
their decorations
and having a lot of fun, right?
So, I´m riding into work
on a bike,
because of course
everybody rides bikes.
-There you go.
-And where we worked, it was
still also a neighborhood,
so there´s little kids
going to school
same time I´m riding to work.
But on this day in the holidays
the kids all have black face on.
-Yeah.
-You know, like black face.
-This is a real thing.
-Like, hey --
[ Laughter ]
"I´m a little kid, you know."
And it was weird.
-Yeah.
-And then they saw me
and they´d go --
[ Speaking foreign language ]
Which means "black Pete."
[ Laughter ]
And they were really happy
about it.
-Yeah. They were happy
to see black Pete.
-Yeah, see, ´cause the thing is,
is that in Holland Santa Claus,
he doesn´t have little elves
that help him deliver toys.
He has straight-up slaves.
[ Laughter ]
And they portray those slaves
by having white Dutch people
put on black face
and run around.
And the story goes
if you´re a bad kid,
these slaves will throw you in a
sack and take you back to Spain.
[ Laughter ]
-It´s a bummer story.
-It´s a bummer story all around,
especially for the slaves.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And so what did you say
to the children
who were saying black Pete
to you?
-I didn´t say much.
I fought them.
All of them.
[ Laughter ]
All of Holland´s children.
-I remember
you did a sketch as a --
-We did.
Actually, me and Jordan Peele.
-Jordan Peele
from "Key & Peele."
You guys played a couple of
aggressive black Petes.
-Yeah.
-And it was a fantastic sketch.
And I think that --
-That´s how we fought back.
We fought back with a rap song.
-So you met Jordan out there.
-I did.
-Jordan Peele.
And then you wrote for
"Key & Peele."
And Jordan, who wrote and
directed the film, "Get Out" --
a fantastic horror film.
-That´s right.
Did you guys see that?
Wow.
-He -- Do you remember?
Because he had that idea
for years.
Do you remember the first time
he told you about it?
-Oh, yeah. I remember the first
time he told it to me.
And, you know, spoiler alert --
has something to do
with black people
getting their head cut off.
And I was like, "What?
You´re going to make
a whole movie about it?"
And he was like, "Yeah, man,
I think I´m going do it."
And he did it!
-He did it.
-And he nailed it.
-He fully nailed it.
-He nailed it.
-So you guys -- So then you went
and you wrote for "Key & Peele."
-I did.
-And were there any sketches
that sort of --
that you worked on that came out
of sort of working with people
you´ve known for a long time?
-Yeah. The best thing about
working on a show
like "Key & Peele,"
we were all just friends.
And so a lot of sketches just
came out of kind of hanging out.
You know how that is sort of
in the sketch room.
So, one time I showed up
to a meeting,
and there was no more chair
for me to sit in.
And so I just kind of
leaned on this cabinet
that was not very steady.
And I´m not a little guy,
so I probably shouldn´t lean on
unsteady cabinets.
Of course everyone´s like,
"Hey, Colton, why don´t you just
go grab a chair?"
And I´m like,
"Nah, I´m good, I´m good.
I´m gonna stay here."
And they´re like, "Really, we
think you should get the chair."
"No, I´m cool, man.
I don´t wanna --
I don´t -- I don´t use chairs!"
And of course we made a sketch
about that.
So, if you can,
check out "Proud Thug."
Just put that in Google,
look up,
and you´ll see a sketch
about a guy
who refuses to sit in a chair.
[ Laughter ]
-That´s fantastic.
That´s how easy comedy writing
could be on a good day.
When you´re with your friends
on a good day.
-I typed that up and I was gone.
Slid down the dinosaur tail.
-You didn´t need a seat.
You were in and out.
So you on "Superstore,"
you play customer service.
-I do.
-You do customer service.
Did you ever have a job
like that in real life?
-Oh, I did.
You know, I actually --
I worked at a video store.
And what a video store was
is a store
where people would go to...
[ Laughter ]
...and they´d rent a video
and then they´d take it home.
They´d watch it and then they´d
take it back to me
and I would put it on a shelf
and somebody else would --
-Now, let´s say there´s a movie
I really want to see
and I come in
and you don´t have it.
Did you have another one
that you could give me?
-I mean, I would have all sorts
of recommendations
for other movies,
maybe in a similar genre
that you could rent.
-Gotcha.
-Basically I was Netflix...
-Yeah.
-...before Netflix.
-That´s great.
-That´s what I was, yeah.
[ Applause ]
-And did you like
your video-store life?
-No. I mean, I liked the free
movies that I got to watch,
because again this was before
you could just get free movies.
-Right.
-So I loved that.
But the thing that connects
me and Garrett is
he works in customer service
and both of us
do not like customers
and we don´t like service.
-Yeah.
So you draw on that
in your performance.
-I draw on that
strong experience.
-Well, man, it´s great seeing
you every week on TV.
And it´s great having you here
in person.
-Buddy, thanks for having me.
-Always such a delight.